all right now pause for a moment I'm
about to do a lot of algebraic work on
uh this equation that you can see here
however there are a few things that I
can do to make all of that algebraic
soup a little easier to Wade through for
starters everything that I'm going to do
to X right I'm going to do some
expansion and some simplifying obviously
and I want to try and get towards
something like this though you will know
because I've got zero here and I don't
have zero here I'm going to have to add
things to both sides and that accounts
for the difference between what you can
see on my result that I'm Desiring and
what I'm starting with here but
hopefully you can see that everything
here with x's is equivalent to
everything you can see here with y's
right like literally uh this this
statement here
this oops it is this expression here is
identical to this expression here except
I've switched X's for y's so everything
that I'm going to do in terms of
manipulating symbols I don't really need
to do it twice and just write it once
for x's and write it another time for
y's everything I need to do I can just
do it once and then just kind of repeat
that that argument so it's a little bit
like you know this argument that I made
here with the alphas and the beaters
being you know I would say similarly I
don't have to write the whole piece of
logic there and I'm going to do the same
thing here with my algebra so I don't
need to do it twice the other theme that
I want to point out is because of the
way that I have created this situation
right I've got um this is an x
coordinate this is a y coordinate so is
this it's a fairly standard way to call
this X1 y1 because I've I've got more
than one x coordinate more than one y
coordinate so I obviously don't want to
mix them up however because I'm going to
be writing with these a lot it's going
to be easier for me if I don't have
subscripts flying around I'm going to
have quadratics as well so what I'm
going to do is instead of calling this
X1 and X2 just temporarily to make it
easier for me to handle I'm going to
call this X1 you
yeah sorry yeah and the X2 I'm going to
call V it's just going to make it easier
for me to uh write and and say as well
so here's what I'm going to do I'm going
to consider and I'll do this in Orange
because
um you can follow the flow of argument a
little more easily
so having done this substitution here
what I'm going to do is I'm going to say
consider
just this thing we have on the left x
minus X1 oh what did I say I'm replacing
it with a u that's what I want x minus u
x minus V and consider if I just had
that and just that was equal to zero now
obviously this is not actually true I
really have these y's flying around but
I just want to see what happens here
when I manipulate the algebra okay
now again I'm heading towards a
quadratic of some kind so let's get that
quadratic there
um and I'm going to do that by expanding
everything out so you can see I've got x
squared minus u x
v x they're both negative just watch
those signs and then the double negative
uh becomes a positive when I multiply
them together so I've got UV there and
that's equal to zero
now I can tidy this up just a teeny
little bit again to make the quadratic a
little more obvious you can see here
that I've got
and x squared I can factor out that X
and that gives me a u H minus U minus V
but I've I've even factored out the
minus sign as well plus the X and before
I write the rest of the line here I just
want to pause for a minute right where
am I headed this is one of the tricky
things
um that really taxes your working memory
and your cognitive load when you're
doing any kind of um proof like this you
always want to keep one eye on the
algebra that you're manipulating so you
don't make any mistakes but you also
want to keep one eye on what your
destination is like where are you headed
okay now this is the part of my equation
that has to do with the x's and what you
can see here is it's a perfect square
I don't have a perfect square here or
here right so what I want to do is
create a perfect square and we have an
algebraic technique that allows us to do
that when you're starting with something
that isn't a perfect square and it's
called completing the square like what
I've got here if I were to draw a
diagram it's like a square with a piece
missing from it and I've I've taught
this and I've got videos for it I might
link them below so you can see them so
that's why I'm thinking completing the
square will be a useful strategy to do
here because I want to get a perfect
square uh this this can this thing here
and I don't have one so I'm going to
have to make it right now to make that a
little bit simpler for me to make the
perfect square I will just leave this
set of terms over here
and I will move that UV or I'll subtract
that UV from both sides all right now I
might as well just use this line of
working to carry it on here right if I
just focus here
completing the square is about adding a
certain constant to both sides of an
equation such that what you have on the
left hand side is the expanded version
of uh a perfect binomial square right so
what is that thing well you have to look
at this coefficient in here and what you
want to do
if I have a look at this coefficient in
here you may recall if you've learned
Community Square recently or if you
learned it a long time ago but you did
it so many times it's still in your
memory what you want to do with that
coefficient is half it and square it
have it and square it so when I harvest
what I get is U plus v over 2
U plus v over 2 and then I Square it
that's it this is the theme that I add
to both sides so if I take this
and duplicate it over here
I have an equation that is still true
it's still all balanced because I add
the same thing to both sides now what
I've got on the left hand side is a
perfect square if you can't quite see it
the whole idea here is that if I've got
something like say well there's a minus
sign there so it's a minus 2 a B plus b
squared the thing that we just added was
this B squared here okay this is going
to be equal to a minus b or squared and
you can see why I added this thing here
it's it's it's added because whatever
you get over here even if there's a
minus sign it's going to end up positive
right so here's my perfect square what I
need to do is just do the a minus B part
of it right
so what I can do is I can say oh this is
this is the A and this is the B okay so
I'll have uh X take away U plus v on two
and that's all squared and you can
verify for yourself if you like that uh
when you take this and you expand it out
you will end up with this thing over
here
okay now I've successfully created that
perfect square I wanted on the left but
I've got a bit of a mess over here on
the right so let's let's work on that
shall we the first thing I notice is
that this UV right this will make minus
UV right there's going to be some UV
terms in here once I expand it out so
it's in my interest to actually even
though it's simple when it is in a
factorized form if I expand it out I can
collect some like terms I also notice
this is a minus so I'm going to shift
the order of this to make it a little
easier to read
so just so you can follow where this
comes from right I'm going to write this
in purple so you can see where it comes
from I'm going to uh uh let's write that
as 1 over 2 squared is a quarter so I'm
squaring that out that's expanded now
and then I'm going to square the
numerator so this is going to be U
squared plus 2 U V there's that UV term
that I want to collect like terms with
and then there's going to be a v squared
as well
that is take away u v right now this is
all one line together now so I'm going
to stop writing them as separate colors
hopefully you can see here that if I
want to collect like terms here this UV
needs to make it inside the brackets but
there's a quarter at the front right so
this is if you want to think about it
this way
this part here is the same as uh a
quarter times four UV you see how that
the quarter and the four they just
cancel out so if I I considered this UV
as a quarter times four UV now I have
this constant
um or rather this uh common factor of a
quarter so I'll write that quarter out
the front
and then I've Got U squared plus 2 UV
plus v squared uh take away the four UV
that I just uh got from here okay so you
can see that's snuck in and I'm going to
get these terms here which are going to
collect so let's keep on doing that
algebraic work
uh U squared minus 2uv now plus v
squared and what's great is this came
from a a perfect square and it's now
ended up as a different perfect square
this is actually something that comes up
a lot algebraically when you're doing
proofs like this so it's uh not U plus V
all squared that minus in there means
that I've got a quarter of U minus V all
squared okay
so uh as a final sort of note you can
see that I can sort of i i squared a
half uh here
here to become a quarter at the front
just so I can deal with this separately
but now that I've got a perfect square
back I can put that quarter back in as
one over two squared so you can see that
this is actually uh you take away V on
to
all squared right so you can see that
numerator becomes the U minus v o
squared here and then the denominator
becomes the quarter out the front
so this is great what I've got here
we don't need to have that there what
you can see here is I've got that left
hand side over there which is the
perfect square I wanted and then I have
something over here on the right hand
side which compensated for what I had to
add
okay now uh let's think about what this
means what are the implications for the
original working that we were doing well
let's remember what u and v were
substitutes for I'm going to go back
into black because that's how I wrote
this right so here's the U and the V
that I had before let me just copy this
and put it nearby just so that I can see
it
okay so remembering that what I can say
is well if I don't write it as using V's
anymore because I just did that for
convenience right what I've got is x
minus U is X1
V is X2 that's all divided by 2.
that's squared and then what I have on
the right hand side is a subtraction so
it's X1 minus X2 all over 2 squared okay